my name is Matt we're going to be
looking at the iterator pattern today
here in design patterns and basically
going over how this is useful when you
should use it and some things you
probably well you may or may not know
all right well we're just going to do
this in C plus plus write up some code
and we're using our standard design
patterns repo link below and uh yeah
you'll now see an iterator folder and
we're going to of course add that as a
subdirectory and our C major and we
should be ready to start coding it out
there's that
and there's that all right so what is an
iterator and what's it for let's at
least cover those Basics most people
already know but we'll say it for sake
of clarity at in this video as well so
in a nutshell an iterator is designed to
go over certain elements in a collection
and uh Traverse through and get you what
you want now the point of an iterator
here is basically to be able to go
through your data in in different ways
or in different Fashions and also to
Traverse any data type without revealing
the underlying data type that way from a
client end and you just basically
Traverse through and get what you need
and don't have to worry about what's
going on behind the scenes so it
basically works like an interface to go
through a collection of any sort and we
can make it Dynamic and we can change
them on the fly if we decide we want
them to work a different way and there's
some usage like that so let's just make
an example and we'll talk about things
little further as we go now you might
already know that c plus has some
standard iterator types in their
standard template library for most of
their collection types so for example uh
well let's include string here we're
probably going to use that some and
let's include Vector we're probably
going to mess with the vector a little
bit but this essentially Works about the
same or
maps and any of the other types that you
can think of so the first thing we want
to do is we want to define a few things
let's let's work on our iterator first
so let's make a template class here with
type name t and t is going to be
basically the type we're iterating
through and another type name here and
this one is going to be our container
class I'm just going to call it U and
that'll make more sense later if you're
not sure about that so just stay tuned
here and we're going to make an iterator
class like that so let's make some
public members
and uh we're gonna first of all just do
a type def all right because it's going
to need to be defined based on these
type names so type def type name and uh
let's say we're going to work with
Vector here so we're going to go Vector
of types T iterator so whatever the type
we want to iterate over is going to be
like uh it's going to be defined here
so
this needs a name let's just call it uh
hitter type is fine
or we'll just call it it type in this
case
all right so we got that taken care of
now let's make an actual Constructor for
this class uh based on these types as
well so
this one here is going to be our
container class essentially and we want
a pointer to that so let's just call it
data there
and that's really all we need you can
add more parameters and a lot of
examples you see some different ways of
setting it up for example they might
have something like reverse here that
you can specify but we're going to kind
of ignore that for now because as you'll
see this you can design this however you
want to iterate however you want but we
want to keep this example simple but
just know that you can expand it as
needed so we're passing in data here I'm
going to skip ahead a little bit and
just put our data class down here now
the iterator itself doesn't need to hold
all the data it only needs to hold the
current data that it's at and of course
it needs to know how to get to the next
Parts but we'll get to that shortly so
mainly we're going to have this you
container class well it's going to have
a pointer to The Container class
but it doesn't need to make a copy of
all the data it's just it's just a
pointer to the actual data so you'll
notice some other things here like
there's not going to be a Destructor
we're not going to be destroying this
data because that's handled by the
container class itself the iterator only
holds weak references so it doesn't like
do any deleting of data or anything so
just be aware of that all right so let's
get that down and let's get the
container class down here we'll just
call it m data um maybe I'll call it
yeah I usually like call on these when
it's non-owned something like ref it's
just a personal preference because you
know hey it's a reference it's not we
don't own the data so we're not going to
be deleting or anything anyway we need
to get that in here because it's part of
this we need to construct it data ref
and then just make it
pointer that we pass in and now also in
the body of this Constructor well we
want to get this an iterator initialized
now
um by default you probably wouldn't
start at the beginning you'd imagine
right
but if you don't uh you can change it as
needed so we need an iterator let's make
a private iterator here and I'll just
call it uh well we know that it is this
iterator types
um we've already decided we're going to
be using vectors here so that's kind of
tied in so basically we're just going to
use this type and we'll just call it uh
I guess we'll just call it header or
maybe it it's this I just find it weird
just repeatedly say words like it or if
I say enter this whole time it's just
going to sound weird after a while at
least it does to me I like to try to use
variable names that are easier to say
oddly enough I don't know if that people
care about that at all but when I was a
new coder it always threw me off to hear
people say these really awkward words
over and over like they were known words
except they weren't known to anybody
except people deep in that programming
language so I'm trying to keep a little
more generic here and not use too many
acronyms and stuff other than it for
iterator but I like it because it's it
specifies uh it's it's kind of by
default already a proper word like which
data are we at this one it is it I don't
know all right let's move on so we want
to set the iterator is what I'm getting
to here so we're just going to say well
let's start the iterator at the
beginning so we will take the data that
we're at here uh so it's going to be
this data ref
and then we want the well it's kind of
hard to say we know it's a vector right
some kind of vector so it's going to
have data itself
but actually Let's see we can't really
go a whole lot further with this because
we need to know more about this data
which we haven't specified yet other
than it's a vector of something so
uh we'll need to do a little head
designing to get that sorted out because
basically it's going to say hey take the
data ref take the data at the beginning
so it's going to look something like
that but we haven't designed it yet so
we'll have to come back to that I'm just
going to leave it like like that for now
all right so let's uh let's pop down a
little bit let's just go ahead and
design
um the classes that these are going to
work around so this is the thing with
iterators you typically design them
based on some classes and uh well we'll
get to a few more advanced things a
little later but let's go ahead and make
our container class so we want to look
at the what is going to be the U in this
case and this is also going to
it's going to have inside of it as a
data type a vector of type T so we're
essentially going to have three classes
here so let's go ahead and do that we
just want a template and once again
we're going to use type name here and
this time it's just T because this is
going to be the U in our case and we'll
just call this uh containers fine
call something else if you want
it's more relevant sometimes people call
these bag or something else or storage
and in this one we want to make sure we
are a friend of this iterator here so
friend of class iterator since we named
it iterator
and also we want to sure be sure we put
the T in here and then now what is the U
well it's this class here so we can just
put container we don't want to use this
one's already specified so now
as long as you instantiate this iterator
this container uh this iterator will be
able or this iterator will be able to
access private members of the container
and it will be the only thing that can
so that's kind of the point here is only
the integrator can get to the data the
client and get through the to the data
through iterators and they have a public
way of accessing it but it's still
pretty well protected otherwise all
right so let's just go ahead and work
this class up privately we want the data
it can be any type of data for now let's
just use integers but keep in mind this
could actually be anything or you could
have several types here I guess we'll
just call this uh
I just stay that's kind of a
I don't know it seems like everybody
does their private variables differently
I guess I'll start it with an underscore
in this case here uh these ones I'm not
going to now let's stay consistent fine
I'll start all our privates with an
underscore in this particular example
but you know it's up to user preference
how you want to do that most people a
lot of people put an M or a p in front
of them like like so but we're gonna
stick with underscore Okay so we've got
the friend class of the iterator we've
got the private data and now really
um this data isn't exactly correct if we
think about it we actually need it to be
a vector of the data so let's go ahead
and just do that we'll go standard
Vector uh not an integer but of type T
of the data
just like so
so now it will actually work now this is
really all you need but let's just add
um some some stuff that kind of just
makes sense like let's make a uh
Constructor here
and maybe an ad we could even have it
removed but we'll skip that for now uh
yeah let's just let's just make some
let's make an add method so we'll go add
now we need to add a type T and uh
need a name here
uh we'll just call it to add I guess
that's fine and really all we're going
to do is just do a pushback of this new
data data dot pushback you add well two
add kind of sounds weird because you
think oh you're adding things together
no
um it's just new data push back new data
just adding it to the list and that's
pretty standard Vector operation there
but of course as you can see from this
container you couldn't add data normally
because it's private so you would have
to use this add method from the
container after you instantiate the
container and see do we need anything
else I guess we could uh
we could set up the iterator or well you
want a way to get an iterator for this
class so basically we already know about
the iterator but to create a proper
iterator for this class well it's sort
of something this class has to do so we
want to make another public method that
Returns the iterator we want and we'll
just return a pointer like so let's call
it create iterator that should work and
in the body of the function we just want
to return a new iterator
type T and of course container so same
type and now in the body here when we
create an iterator needs to know about
some data type right well
the data
well this is container maybe container
would be better here
is essentially a container that stores
the data uh
trying to think of a better name here
maybe I'll just call this bag here in
this case bag bag
okay so you pass it the bag or the
container
now I'm going to make some names I'll
just call it lowercase container here
stick with that so you know naming
conventions do them however you want to
do them I'm just trying to stick with
ones that make the most sense to me um
but the point is when we return this new
iterator we need to pass in the
container and the container is actually
this class here so how do you do that
well you do that it's just the keyword
this which means a pointer to this class
and as you can see it wants a pointer to
a container this is exactly that is a
pointer to a container
hence this function should compile and
work properly and get us that pointer to
an iterator we're somewhat ignoring the
memory management of this because as you
can see we are creating a new iterator
and returning a pointer to it but you're
not going to see anywhere in this code a
uh way to destroy this iterator because
we're kind of skipping over that but as
an exercise you can try to work that in
at the end if you want see if you can
figure out how to properly clean up the
iterator and if you want to update the
code on GitHub and make a full requests
if it looks like it'll work I'll prove
it so a little way you can get some
GitHub points if you want
okay so this is mostly organized now we
still need to uh figure this out a
little bit more
um but we haven't specified what the
actual data is it's some type name t we
could pass in anything you could make
you could now go uh container
of integers
and we could just call this r
data bag or something whatever you want
to call it and that should work that
will basically make a vector of integers
as the data here and uh
then we wanted to Traverse through it we
go our data bag equal dot create
iterator
and make some of the store it there and
we'll just say Auto because of course it
actually needs to be this type let's put
that in there
our iterator and it doesn't like
something about this function oh this
type name t is probably the problem here
I think that's going to need to be an
integer in this container it should be
okay right
ah okay so it's saying inaccessible
because we forgot to put the word public
here in classes default to private if
you don't say public so that should make
that part happy and this one here
uh this should be what argument list for
class template container is missing
okay so we have to specify what the
container is holding and it should be
essentially the same type as the
iterator is holding so I believe we just
want to go int here as well and that
should be happy there we go because it's
a container of ants in each iterator is
also an it so there's essentially how
you would get your iterator and then
once you have your iterator you can do
whatever you need to do with it we know
that this create iterator creates a new
one and when we create a new one it's
going to set it up we haven't completed
this code yet because
we just have a little bit more program
um actually we might be done enough
because okay this iterator
is a friend of the container so it can
access that private data here so we can
just go data dot begin
so now that should be complete the
iterator should start at the beginning
by default and now if we see out the
beginning data or well
uh this is going to start as blank so we
need to add some data first I guess
would be the big thing here let's find
some data to add
um let's see here got an iterator that's
fine so we've got our bag and we've got
our iterator
um we need we should probably add stuff
before we do the iterator but I believe
we set it all up first with uh
some Basics here so I don't know maybe
we'll just add one through ten in a poor
Loop or something
[Laughter]
our bag beta dot add
all right so there we go that should get
us
uh one through ten put in there there we
go
and uh
you know if we want to iterate if we
want to get all of this and like I don't
know retrieve this data we don't really
have a way to do that with this class
other than to create an iterator and
that's where this pattern shines because
this iterator is generic all it needs is
to have the right type in the right
container but how it's designed
is totally up to you
so you can design different iterators
and set different iterators to make them
work in different ways that's
essentially the point now this is a very
straightforward one where we're just
going to go from beginning to end but if
you've got a more complicated data set
um for example maybe you have an
inventory in a video game and you have
some sort buttons that the end user can
press you can sort by weight you can
sort by quantity you can sort by cell
value and things like that now the
question is every time the player hits
sort you want to rearrange all the data
and move a bunch of data around and that
that's you know a real basic solution
but if someone's like spam clicking it
or everyone on the server is clicking
sort inventory you might get some weird
stuff happening especially if you
haven't thought of all the potentials of
race conditions or something
I don't know that might be a over
contrived example but rather than
reorganize the data you could just
change the iterator you could say okay
get us a sort by weight iterator and
rather than rearrange the data you just
make a new iterator in the iterator as
it looks for the next piece of data it
just goes to the next weight it might be
a little slower uh
client end you know to find the next
each next item but it'll be faster
because you'll never have to sort
everything a million times you know when
you when you sort stuff it doesn't
actually sort it just changes the
iterator
so there's cases like that where it
makes sense to just get a different
iterator rather than sort your whole
array again and that could be for
anything if you're like paying servers
you could have a server iterator that
looks for the lowest ping and then the
next lowest ping and stuff like that can
happen too you can essentially use this
for anything where you want to uh just
go through every item and you might want
to change how you go through the items
that's when you would set a different
iterator all right let's let's continue
with the example so we've got all this
in here got some stuff in our data bag
we've got a custom iterator a very very
default one we need to work up this
iterator a little bit more it just
doesn't quite do it enough yet like it
doesn't go to the next reference or
anything so let's just put that all in
here but we kind of had to get this
scaffolding done to to make the example
to start so what if we say it's add a
few more new methods here
um you know let's just go off the
standard usually they have first and
what would first do it would set this
iterator to the beginning basically it
would do this same thing again equals
dot again so that would get us the first
data element and we might also have next
all right and with next
um you basically want to return
the next iterator and with these
iterators the way they're made you just
you just do plus plus on them to go to
the next one that'll get you the next
one and
you want to see if you're at the end so
you could have an at end or is done
uh let's go with uh I like that and so
this one we want to return a bowl you
know just are we at the end or not true
or false sometimes you're going to want
to know that so we'll just return
whether the iterator is equal to the end
data so it would just be uh this data
ref
and then the data again
we're just checking if it's equal to the
end and if it is it returns true so
basically and otherwise false so I will
just let us know if the iterator is at
the end of the data or not and that's
really I think all we need for now so
with first next and at end that's good
enough so you know there's there's still
ways of expanding this that you could
probably think of I'll mention real
quickly like in most of these previous
examples we have had some sort of
interface class so if you make your you
make an interface class for these
iterators that's when you could have
within your container somewhere you
could have one that you could set that's
we're not going to quite go that far but
that's how you would change them out on
the Fly it's going to get a little more
complicated because this friend thing
might not work quite as well quite the
same essentially if you store a
reference to it and uh and then you
change it up if you would look something
like this
um
like uh Dynamic yeah I would call it
Dynamic it
with this sort of setup
well we still got create iterator and it
kind of doesn't really quite work like I
would think with this because we have a
create iterator with this case instead
of create iterator you would have to
create it on your own and then set it uh
so it would look a little something like
uh they have a void set iterator and
then you pass it a pointer to
a real iterator and this would also need
to be
the interface class here that needs to
be set to a real one all right I'm
probably making this Complicated by
saying all that but uh
you know just it would look like this
you know and we'd put any methods
required in here make sure they're
virtual you know that whole yeah look at
the previous any of the previous
episodes about how to do the interfaces
but essentially you would make
an interface for this that has these
core methods and have it so that you set
it in here and then you could change
your iterators on the Fly
so that could be another thing you could
uh play around with and see if we can
get that to work it's like a homework
thing but I think I've covered that
whole interface thing so many times and
all the previous episodes that you could
probably figure out how to adapt it to
this uh interface way but the point is
you can dynamically change them too if
that is desired but if it's not really
desired maybe you've only got one or two
things you ever do you could just make
uh iterators for them like you could say
create uh begin to end iterator for
example and that just you know goes from
beginning to end maybe you have create
uh sort by weight iterator and it does a
special one that you know as we talked
about earlier goes you know goes and
finds the whatever the smallest weight
to the largest as you iterate through
but it all depends on how you design it
to go through the data now it gets a
little tricky because you know this
iterator it doesn't actually know the
data type yet so it depends but you know
this is one of those things where you
can go in so many different directions
that uh it's hard to cover them all in
one video so I think this nice little
generic example is probably good enough
all right so let's work up the client
code a little bit then we'll call it a
video because I've kind of talked about
a lot of stuff but you know to go into
it all I'd be here for like three hours
over explaining everything so let's just
call it a day so client code you know we
made our bag we made it of integers
container of integers we added some data
to it very nice
and then we made an iterator
um that just create iterator now if you
don't want to remember all the syntax
you can just you can just go Autos make
sure you get the uh the star in there
because Auto doesn't deduce that and uh
and if you have any sort of syntax
correction when you hover over Auto it
should show you the type down below as
you can see it's uh what we had in there
before so that's always nice and then
you can just go through it and you just
go through it with like a for Loop is
fine so we would go R iterator you let's
do first started at the beginning here
and then let's say it while it's not at
end so not our iterator DOT at the end
so while it's not at the end we'll keep
going and here for the uh next one we're
just gonna do a a DOT next
if you ever worked with iterators this
is probably all very straightforward but
this should give you an idea of how to
make your own and how to customize them
because normally when you work with them
you know you just do the uh you just do
data dot begin but now that it's like
abstracted away you've got these
functions I essentially do what you
would expect usually that's how you
start your iterator that's how you go to
the next one that's how you check if
it's at the end or not and we've just
put that in a class and that's that's
basically it all right what am I missing
here just needs is the pointer yeah
iterators are a little pointer there
and there we go we could just uh see out
the data here um
so if we just do it not underscore data
I think what we're doing we're gonna
make a few Corrections here make sure
this is uh everywhere and we typed it
that's underscore it
and uh I think we're good same with
these data refs so just correcting a few
small things here so we can compile
we've mostly got it working here but
just a little thing we're trying to see
out the data uh but okay so when you you
can't just see out the iterator because
you know the iterator is this entire
class here and it has no idea sure you
could overload the uh you know the
Operator Operator this this whole
operator and do it that way but instead
we're just gonna make a method that just
gets the actual iterator this one here
um that's in the
standard library and we could just do
that by making a function that returns
it so we got that it type here and we
could just say we'll just say current
and all that's going to do is return
whatever this iterator currently is and
that's it and that way we just have a
way to access the data it's pointing at
so we'd go our iterator current and that
will get us pointer to the data so now
we need to dereference that pointer and
there we should get the number now when
we hit play we should see 0 through 9 I
believe let's make a separating with end
lines
that way they'll each be on their own
line and it should be pretty clear and
if we don't have any bugs oh we got some
bug let's see what we got here we got
zero and then when it tried to go to the
next one it crashed let's figure out why
well in case you haven't noticed yet I
made a bit of an error when I put a plus
plus on this our iterator that doesn't
work because well it's going it is going
and they know it is incrementing as you
would think but we're incrementing this
entire class not the iterator itself so
we need to call Dot next which actually
implements the iterator because you
can't plus plus this class I mean you
can but and it compiles but it's just
going to crash because it's just going
to some random piece of memory that's
not relevant so we need to call Dot next
now obviously once again we could
overload operators we could over
overload this plus plus to call next a
similar way you know you can look that
up if you want do it as a experiment but
you could overload that to basically
call uh if plus plus so that way if they
call plus plus on this class it will do
what you would expect but yeah we're not
going to do that we're just going to use
next but uh just so that that's out
there so instead of plus plus here we
need to make sure we call next
and then we shouldn't be running off
into random memory and we should be able
to compile and run this without a crash
and there we go 0 through 9 as expected
and there's an example of how you can
make iterators I talked about how to do
Dynamic throughout obviously I didn't do
that because it and you know it just
gets it gets so deep
very quickly but if you want to Dynamic
iterator you could do that
um you would basically it basically just
gets a little more complicated but
that's a cool way to swap them out on
the fly or you know
just have different ones that you set
when you call this create iterator you
could have different ones ready to go
that you could create to get different
types of iterators and you could
essentially design the iterator up to uh
to go through the data how you want from
beginning to end is the standard but
maybe you want to go from end to
beginning or you want to based on this
data type
do a certain thing so
just a cool pattern generally already
pre-implemented for you in the standard
template library but uh now that you've
seen more about them hopefully this can
give you some ideas how to go forward
how to not sort your data in arrays and
vectors constantly if you're doing that
it's probably going to be superior to
using iterator pattern instead all right
well I hope you've enjoyed this episode
let me know if you have any questions if
there's a lot of stuff and a lot of
questions and you guys really want to
see a lot more examples or you want to
see a dynamic example just leave a
comment down below you know if a bunch
of people say it or want to see it I
will do one um but yeah I think we're
just going to keep this one nice and
simple and leave it off here all right I
will see you in the next episode take it
easy guys peace out
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]